so it was by luck huh kind of like a
fluke not even really luck though it's
like
I don't know I always know it's gonna be
something like you know what I'm saying
so I don't think it was like I think it
was just guys showing me where to go
[Music]
[Applause]
perfect yo what's up guys I'm Thomas
dopas yo whatever you want to call me
here with my co-host Marty O'Neill
what's up guys guys this episode of the
dope's usual podcast is gonna be very
fun I'm super excited you guys been
excited since we announced it this is
the route 49 episode oh it's definitely
for being here we can't remember yet it
don't even matter honestly whatever
yeah you're good you're good they should
be in here dude
I mean I won't get on the subject but yo
that outfit thank you wild you like it I
like it it reminds me a little bit of
the cringe the Grinch I like it though I
like it I like it though so let's get
straight off into it I know we know
where you're from but for everybody else
where are you from I'm from New Orleans
New Orleans Louisiana all right is it
cringe to you when people say New
Orleans like no I ain't really no big
deal
it's just New Orleans like this is how
we talk so it's it sounds the same to me
honestly yeah for sure I'm gonna just
jump straight into a note right here my
my assistant's from New Orleans too and
she uh she tells me about some crazy
[__] out there my assistant she just
she's here today no no she's at my
warehouse she's cool but she's
her family's mad occasion I guess you
would call it so you could it's
different when you see white boys
yeah her whole family she's country as
hell yeah what do you eat like I eat
whole alligators
she's been here for like seven years so
when I when I met her yeah she did yeah
so now she's talking more like yeah yeah
she's losing yeah
her brother is it's a different it's a
different breed he reminds me to do some
water boy yeah yeah exactly exactly my
neighbor Mr Edwards uh he was like 90
years old he's from Mississippi yeah I
can't understand a word he said except
mine at Tom but I can't understand but
he's from the value oh man it's two
different type things so like New
Orleans is like more of like the city
the Bayou is like water boy like country
like just bad country yeah
I mean I I tasted it before it tastes
like chicken it's good but I ain't just
around here catching
the one thing I'm matting I've never
been to the South but
here's a lot of paranormal stuff out
there bro now for show facility yeah not
for sure you never you never deal with
that growing up like some panels today
sucks now but I mean it's not like known
for California to have it they have
Voodoo and stuff but I don't know how
real that is because it's real it's real
the Mexicans got the Santeria and you
guys got the voodoo oh yeah
they be reading poems and stuff and they
told it they they tell us like man don't
get your poem read because that's like
bad luck is it bad luck yeah my grandma
used to do that I know a couple people
that got their poem reading exactly what
the lady said exactly what they went
through exactly what my grandma said
about my my hand exactly she's like I'm
not gonna live long she like that she
told you later she said about herself
she's like see my lifeline's short I'll
probably die soon she died like a year
later freaked me out she showed me like
so you're lifelong is so long your
wealth is going to be huge oh my God I
don't even break it I don't even want
you to tell me no you see nine years old
when she did it to me you know
I wouldn't even get into it bro I think
oh the longest line just say that's your
lifeline
oh I hope so
and then I'm like it's just lines in my
hand Grandma I'm like oh she wasn't she
wasn't looking around it's crazy it's
crazy man especially like we're talking
about early the older generation I feel
like for the internet and TV these
people had to entertain themselves
somehow
about to find some paranormal do you
have experience any of that out there
yeah I remember like one day I was in my
um
I think I was like 13 I was in a room
with myself like going to sleep this is
the first that's when I first started
sleeping with the lights off like I
don't know I just was always scared of
the dog yeah when I started seeing with
the lifestyle so I used to put the cover
in my head
man I feel something like sit on the end
of my bed and I started smelling
cigarettes and I'm like man it's getting
did you take the covers off and I didn't
want to sleep damn someone just lived
with you all night it's chill man I
didn't want to see him like man dude
what it is yeah yeah I feel like I don't
know why even though I think there's
monsters as a kid like this blanket gots
me yeah as long as I don't see it um man
listen you know when you when you're
going to sleep man you put your hand
over to um over the bed
my new bed I got has no under the bed
wood goes to the ground I was a kid
remember shutting off your light like
all right running the dark jump over the
beds Chucky don't get your leg I live
like that until I was 24 years old man
like I don't like it at all but then it
got to the house like people's got guns
out here that's more scary than me then
there's monsters yeah guns out here yeah
they break into your house that's that's
why I moved a few times I'm from uh the
valley it's my gang town where are you
from uh Mercedes come by Fresno it's oh
you saw you from Canada yeah I'm from
Cali too no Buffalo are you from Buffalo
so growing up in the South man I gotta I
gotta know so what is it football music
and food correct exactly yeah yeah
because I know just everyone lives for
that football is
God out there like Texas yeah because I
have homies from Texas that says like
the town's empty on Sunday bro music
watch the Cowboys it's a trip dude man
like Green Bay I don't know if you know
but the whole town shuts down for they
only have a couple cops Patrol in the
city it's it everyone shuts down because
season ticket holders over 50 years you
get season tickets for the Packers yeah
you gotta get a pass down from your
great grandpa to go to the game
damn crazy are they the only team
rocking it like that I think so it's the
smallest you know I mean green who wants
to go to Wisconsin I don't think people
live there want to live there so that's
what I'm thinking about the football but
for football for you you guys got their
car now I know uh I'm sorry man listen
you know it's funny like I was a third
call fan here playing for the Raiders
I don't know I don't know how you're
gonna fit in the water it's like I'm I'm
all for those 10 but I just don't know
how you're gonna fit in New Orleans I
don't know man like four years ago you
guys were I mean with true priests and
what's that fool number nine Hill yeah
he's a man
oh yeah yeah number seven yeah that
first place every position yeah he's
crazy so he's he's the Madden character
you put 99 uh-huh he's badass but not
for sure for sure yeah sorry my bad man
we're getting all this other talking
stuff I got a couple notes about uh
stuff coming out for God too coming up
very soon yeah and four guys to the um
the album coming out
like the end of April end of April yeah
in the middle some something like that
yeah how'd that come about because I
read like you had kind of dabbled in
music a little bit you got discouraged
you were down you're basically ready to
quit yeah and then divine intervention
happened I was really quitting but um
Birdman called me and told me he wanted
to sign me so it just motivated me to
keep going you know exactly where you
were standing when you got that call
though I was in a bit eating Rattlers
I spent my last 20 on this rallies I
swear no seasoned fries will get you bro
yeah what bro I had got the um
I got the Lord of fries it was so good
bro
I'm like man it's not it's my last it's
my last tip like what had transpired up
to that point like what how much I just
was lit in the city for real like and
letting the [__] like really I was like
the latest youngin in the city because
you're about 24 yeah I'm 24 I was I was
21 22. when you started doing this yeah
so you just I've read a little bit about
get your perspective on it you're just
with a homie tag along and it was like
yo I could probably make music yeah my
partner was rapping and I'm like man I
don't like I'm the one really like you
know what I'm saying so I just went in
there and just saved my store and
Ireland was like man this him yeah
that's just like that yeah it was like
this him so that was your first thing
ever recorded did you go in there and
just have something written you just
like you let me try nah I just was
freestyle oh is this what you meant to
do then yeah yeah all right you just
picked it up which is him like so I
started going back in by herself not it
um I I really wasn't trying to do the
music they used to be caught I mean like
well you let's go get some food or
something and I go get in the car like I
had to be inside by like eight or
something like that so they used to
hurry up bring me to the store at like
12 we leave at like seven why you happy
inside
so it was by luck huh kind of like a
fluke no kind of like a flu for a sick
though
not even really luck though it's like
I don't know I always know it's gonna be
something like you know what I'm saying
so I don't think it was like I think it
was this guy is showing me where to go
sometimes it takes a lot of time for
things to line up in the way that they
need to to be able to really push
forward you know where it's like just
not the right time if it were to happen
sooner how'd that conversation go oh
what like when you hit you up like and
then he was just like man you lit man I
won't fly you out and at the time me my
mama and my sister well my sister was
already had her own spot well man my mom
was standing again but my little sister
was getting evicted from the house at
the time so he's telling me he gonna
flies out so we gonna fly out tell
everyone
[Music]
that was crazy up there huh it's a
motivational aspect it was just like I
understood I could do this for real like
you know what I'm saying was that your
first time leaving on a live coming to
LA and stuff I had came to L.A do you
know it's funny like the first time I
ever like really looked at my music I
was in L.A matter of fact matter of fact
I was in Vegas huh I was in Vegas but
but we had draw the LA that was my first
time coming to L.A how were you yeah I
was that's that's when I first started
making music I was 21. yeah and this is
a wreath this was like my birthday yeah
it was my birthday damn 21st birthday
that's an epic ass birthday I was in
Frisco drinking nasty ass drinks I was
doing my 21st birthday
[Music]
be smart don't start kick the habit put
it out before it puts you out you've
heard these phrases hundreds of times
throughout your life yet you still
choose to have a bad habit our sponsor
fumes on a mission to accelerate
Humanity's breakup from the bad habits
that consume far too many of us fume is
a natural diffusive device that uses
natural plants and Behavioral Science to
help you trade out your negative habits
for a positive one fume is not a vape
it's a non-electronic device designed to
help you transform your negative habits
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chemicals like a vape fume uses
cores filled with plants like cinnamon
and mint for delicious natural flavors
fume's new version 2 is Snappy high
quality and overall just looks really
nice with an adjustable airflow dial a
magnetic end cap your fingers will
always have something to do the easiest
way to stop a bad habit is to switch to
a positive one and fume has made it
extremely easy for you to do that fume's
number one goal is to make switching
easy and enjoyable so head to trifum.com
and use code Dau to get a 10 off the
journey pack today the journey pack
comes with three unique flavors and the
new version 2 fume to help you Kickstart
your positive habits so guys that's
trifum.com
t-r-y-f-u-m.com and use our code at
checkout d-a-u for 10 off the journey
pack today
question
did you call [__] when he called
like yo this is not [__] Birdman bro
a lot of random number calls you man
brother I know this bird man you know
Birdman you know how he's talk like but
come on just like how he talked did you
like how to expect it at all were you
tied in with him or it was just weird I
used to put um basketball against his
nephew oh so this is was so his nephew
really put him on Me Oh I thought you
were like I knew right man and I guess
he gave my number damn yo what are the
odds of that I know right damn so I was
gonna ask you walked in like oh yeah you
play sports so it's basketball yeah okay
so through all through high school
you're dunking off fools I'm assuming
you're not dunking [__] I don't blame
one time in the game before
I just think everything's Space Jam like
don't dunk
we assumed I could dunking yeah yeah um
you good man I used to be we'll see I'm
gonna get back he's real good and then
you go oh College athletes [__] like all
these fools are athletic College if you
played in college you got to be a little
girl you ain't gonna forget how to play
basketball yeah yeah no that's going to
be my goal I decided I'm about to run
this marathon after the marathon my goal
is by the end of the year I want to be
dunking yeah and I'm it's a Fargo I'm
nowhere near it yeah you remember those
spring shoes for basketball yeah did you
guys ever I was too important oh yeah
but yeah I ain't never had anything I
used to always have the shoes for real
you know someone that had them yeah he
was rich as [__] they met man he was
five two three you're talking about the
Nike Shox oh the best shoes
it wasn't really it wasn't really a
basketball she was just some some
it's sad
[Music]
Nickelodeon was my life as a kid for
real yeah well you said that was that
yours too or what I [__] I was at
Disney Channel baby were you yeah I
never met too many dude I was screwed on
[__] I watched I'm a remember BT
uncut no no no oh you're younger you
guys remember BT uncut awesome smiles
yeah I'm a 106 and poker and [__] oh
yeah but no BTS going wild and [__] like
let's go wild tapes everything was
blurred bet was not blurred we used to
do strip club music videos you watch on
YouTube but after 12 it's called bet uh
uncut and it just show I was 11 like
that little naked asses
my grandma's asleep that's how I know
I'm my first time I watched girls gone
wild with my grandpa was it was Landing
some um some bunk beds he thought I was
asleep must have been
like yo you really paid 24.99 for this
[__] tape I was a kid just being
close to shocked and [__] man that's
crazy they really had that stuff on TV
remember that not a world the world just
watered down now
the world just saw water down so sorry
this to take us back here I'm wondering
so you flew out here I had this moment
too flying out here
you're in La you got this deal in the
works yeah so what happens from there
you just got I might have said we lost
contact oh [__] like three months four
months into me rapping
um Capital hit me up trying to sign me
uh-huh well really this how this is how
it went so one of my home is in a city
named Tony he do clothes and stuff he
had a real connect with Sean cotton
would say cheese oh say cheese
[Music]
so I was I was getting big in the city
so he called me one day this is one of
my real dogs he like man I want you to
do this interview for my friend
so me I'm lit I'm not thinking this is
big like I'm like all right I'm gonna do
it because you're my dog like I pull up
we do the interview and everything
then he like
um
he like um what's your grandma stuff I
get my Gram I'm like oh this [__] got a
blue check your name Sean cotton at the
same at the time I still don't do
nothing about it like yeah but then he
like yeah I'm gonna drop the interview
like like in a couple weeks
and he dropped the interview and he said
I got to say cheese interview
I'm like the [__] yeah and then that's
how I work and then Sean brought me to a
label and Sean was like man that's right
and I wound up signing with them instead
of capital no sure you signed with still
alive
they got um
me hot boy
um
sexy red he got
that they do the first ones that have
like city girls yeah they're on it yeah
you're getting new upcoming artists yeah
[__] when you saw you made the right
choice right yeah for sure yeah Capital
record is cool about something about
that building
I don't know I don't know ominous it's
ominous it's just like a little Eerie I
don't know remember Men In Black where
he walks in to go try to [__] get
them just get the appointments it looks
weird on the outside you coming that's
how I feel like I'm gonna open the door
but I'm outside it looks like Dr evils
yeah some weird [__] well you made a
good choice man you made a good choice
so you lost contact four months in and
you just started going doing your thing
once you do the interview once
everything's coming out you're like damn
my shit's popping like that sick there's
got to be a moment we actually I asked
almost everybody there's a moment when
you're by yourself no one's around you
go
this should happen for real you know you
had that moment you know it's funny like
I I'd be having that moment like like
every now and then like I just be like
damn like
this [__] happening because my myself
coming up just looking at the it don't
matter where they should go from here
like looking at my per my progress from
like day one
like I did it like to myself like you
know what I'm saying like crowd already
yeah I'm proud of myself already so damn
I thought I had to talk with guy a guy
told me oh this is about to happen so
it's really not that far-fetched to me
were you dreaming or you're awake I was
dreaming I had similar dreams couldn't
see the face though huh I couldn't see
the face like me neither you talked to
me I had to go crazy I couldn't see the
face it was almost like too much light
no it was I was an adult he's just
awesome he just talked to me like I
heard his voice
even the [__] you got the grocery store
like am I wasting my time at the grocery
store I can be crushing [__] even before
you started making music I bet he's
getting the itch like I need to do
something or something I'm gonna every
every person or artist you talk to has
that exact same feeling like I don't
know what I'm gonna do but watch I
worked that Subway for a day for a day
well really like more than a day like
three days but I remember telling myself
like man not for me it's not for me like
you're gonna get caught in this and
we're not about to do that yeah I
remember how were you when you got that
job
I know we're like 19 . oh so it's After
High School yeah so I was in high school
at 19. I was in 12th grade oh okay I'm
yeah I'm 17 if I can sit here and [__]
but yeah I was working you know
Hurricane Katrina hit in New Orleans
yeah so a lot of us like a lot of us
like was this place and [__] fine
yeah I had to do like I had to do first
grade like twice me too what the hell
yeah I did first grade twice because I
moved from another District it started
over we had I had to move to Houston and
then we moved from Houston and it was
all year round schools wasn't back up
yet yeah it was all year round school
for me and I finished almost and then
the next thing you're like well you
start over at the regular school so I
did first grade two times man I was
pissed I remember that [__] I never met
anybody else I had to do that dude and
it's not like your parents could do
anything you just take it my mom was
playing that getting kept back [__]
ain't it but I remember when my partner
got cut back in like third grade you
know you know first day of school they
put y'all in their lives like this first
grade the cigarette it's third grade
they're like all right fourth grade over
here
my brother was still in that line I
wasn't looking like [__] I know they
didn't play with him like that like not
even that you're tall as [__] and
especially as you first grade twice by
who was a sixth grader in my child's
class dunking on everybody
first day of school was like nobody
nobody wants to acknowledge it all right
but we all know like
it's not that you're dumb it's like I
told you to do [__]
but you know what I'm saying though
right it's the same feeling like it was
always the kid with the long white tee
with a little bit of black tea under
showing you know that gangster kid
I'm right now you really right like you
two will be so gays and look at you yup
like you stupid ass we're all driving
you're a freshman nah bro I I went
through all that like I said my town
it's the same [__] bro
driver you're a freshman sucks you funny
as hell I remember that [__] though I
think we all could relate in some kind
of way like he's doing [__] yeah me too
like a
interviews podcast
somebody could say or [__] music
somebody say one lyric it sticks with
you forever I [__] with that fool
because you said that that means if he
likes that he must be liking this if I
like that [__]
you remember one of those
I feel like that about future like
you said a couple damn like damn like
you must think like me now then you're
hooked and then you hooked yeah it was
Matt it was Mac Dre for me I know we
talked about recently I never thought
about that yeah if something was it was
a stick forever or watching a new show
and you like that that character that's
my [__] that [__] is funny it's
just something that sticks but with
music it's Universal you could not speak
English listen to a song from America
yeah I like that's just beat [__] but
when you when you know what they're
talking about bro it could last forever
I'm sure you would something stuck with
you when you were young Daisy or DMX
yeah a little Mario bouncing yeah
[Laughter]
I can only imagine little you barking in
your room his dad was a rock uh a blues
player so Marty did not take after him
so I'm assuming he was like but DMX
posters in my kids room damn it you was
a DMX fan oh yeah I love them yeah
he's on the wall you know what's funny
that's one of the only on like one of
the only people I want to feed I wanted
to feature with yeah I swear you got
that kind of energy oh if you win the
past that's that's about the only like
like older guy that I would love to do a
future with it's just different kind of
energy it's just it's just I feel like
[__] like I remember you know what's
funny you know made me start liking them
makes someone [__] you up when I met
Birdman they can't got me from a hotel
his brother he um he was driving up the
hills it was it was late at night like
probably 12 at night and just bumping at
them here we go again imagine that
bumping loud
his black driving up the hill I'm scared
no it was the mid back um
I'm scared of the project so it's like
damn like
this [__] feel like a dream damn like
you know what I'm saying I just got
hooked on things my first time really
hearing them yeah for real yeah he put
me on him he was playing different [__]
he like man listen to this listen to
this man you go back to Stark and hell
it's hot flashing my flash I ain't gonna
lie like I gotta go back I don't I don't
know the names of them but yeah I can
show them to you like oh yeah it's just
like that all my likes look at this [__]
I'll be listening to them prayers get to
line yeah his intros were like the best
part of the album down there oh bro did
you see dolly man you know it's funny
everybody keeps saying um
yeah I had a conversation with somebody
about belly I ain't watched belly good
[__] I haven't seen like different
Snippets I'm gonna watch it today he's
like two yeah and how versatile he is
because he's just him no matter what
he's doing if he's acting if he's doing
music I'm gonna watch it today
that kind of leads into I don't know if
you've been watching this but I've been
real into your honor coming out of New
Orleans you know it's funny somebody was
just telling me about that I got it yeah
that's funny [__] to watch man on your
flight back to money told me
um that she she she was watching this
show and she heard a [__] with my voice
she like man it sounded like Rob so I
gotta watch it man start acting bro yeah
you should I was talking to Birdman he
supposed to be doing um baller blocking
too
I feel like you you you could do a lot
of a lot in that field bro no for sure
because like oh your voice first off
people [__] with it then you're looking
like danceful stood up off Jesus Christ
play a henchman Jesus for real you could
do whatever you want definitely could
have played a lot of foils on the
[__] your honor that's for damn sure
it's a great show though it'd be
interesting to get your take on their
how they depicted New Orleans because it
was very just cinematic and how they did
it for real yeah I'm gonna go watch him
yeah that and uh American Horror Story
I think my favorite shoes right now
probably um you
um you was good man I like really my
favorite show Money how he's for real
bloody nice I never heard of it
you watch snowfall no you lucky as [__]
though oh see that must be a good show
like I wish I could watch it again for
you you know what I'm saying I wish I
could watch it for the first time I
think about that all the time for
certain [__] I ain't gonna lie bro go
watch money guys you gonna thank me
later I swear to God it's so good you
better hit me up on the ground like you
told me to watch money she changed my
life
I'm telling you money how is one of them
bro you gonna be inside and I want to go
to work if you if you do a long time
it's gonna be you know you know when you
have that when you have that show it's
like
it brings refreshment to your life a
hundred percent like I want to wake up
like yeah another Thursday [__] on
Netflix yes
no more it has to be binge watching I
can't do it no more uh-huh you're gonna
be like man I gotta watch the next
episode when I wake up tomorrow like
you're gonna be excited about tomorrow
yeah you'll be up at four in the morning
like I should be asleep I should be
asleep I can't stop watching it I did
that [__] with snowfall man bro do money
Heist for me all right I'll watch it
I'll watch it you watch belly I'm
watching I don't watch money you watch
money no I'm about to get on Lucky ain't
none of y'all watch money
uh we're looking for we just wrapped up
here
you liked it or you loved it
yo uh random what's your favorite three
movies American Gangster paid in full
which are three all three as a whole it
goes it plays together yeah I feel like
damn that seems painful and Godfather
always on our desktop yeah for real
three times
same exact up yeah that's what he said
American Gangster he didn't say American
Gangster but he said
with the world
man what my 100 I I totally get there's
a blueprint for everything dude man what
that's a blueprint for life yeah golf I
was great but that's how I live my life
based on the Godfather um for sure yeah
up and down like as far as like morals
and shows morals and everything yeah
it's a good series or a good Trilogy man
like number three damn it took a long
time to to make that [__] that phone was
45 years old by the time they got to Al
Pacino's daughter getting shot and [__]
um again Al Pacino number one you watch
Godfather yeah looks like an Italian
number two still three kind of looking
American how the hell this will play a
Cuban so well I will never know how do
you do Scarface
that last Godfather he looked different
completely different now when his when
he when when his daughter got shot that
showed me that girls like you cannot put
girls in your business like you gotta
separate that oh damn because if you're
out in public like business should never
be handling the public that's what that
show me that's what I'm telling you like
is what I like
was hard he seemed his pondering moment
you know what's going through a lot yeah
you're scanning your brain right now
it's hard bro okay look at this dude
what's my what's my fifth one though
um supposed to be belly
yeah
it just starts off like oh damn this is
what we're getting into it's a good
movie man you ever watch eat who he
Al Pacino Robert De Niro here what's
that no I know she watched that it's
like a set in La like 1990 was a cop
once a bank robber money Heist one
steals rank truck brings trucks watch
that [__] that's a good ass movie all
right so Val Kilmer's in that one too
I don't know I was a [__] kid I gotta
watch it for sure no what about I'm from
Buffalo like we said but I still grew up
on like New Orleans music that was my
[__] the whole No Limit the whole Cash
Money era I had all that we stole a low
end CDs twice we had all that [__] like
because we you know like Block is Hot
all that did you grow up like uh really
appreciate and all that being like kind
of born after that generation that was a
I was a big win fan growing up like I
wasn't trying to be like Wayne but his
music just was it I wasn't listening to
the other deer reminding me so much of
like high school and when I thought I
wasn't gonna be [__] what era of him are
you talking about like I would listen to
that how'd I go Hollywood how to go
Hollywood to how to go to go Hollywood
I'm just like
I had
from listening to this in the gym every
day to to now I'm doing what I'm doing
I'm like damn
your other self will look at you and be
like I was thinking this [__]
yeah you wanted him
but you yeah you say you didn't think
you're gonna be [__] but you still kind
of did like not then think I wasn't on
Pizza it's just like you need something
about somebody said and I agree at night
that's when he came out with that so
I'm not getting the game as much as [__]
like I'm just thinking like man like
this this was my ride out for myself uh
oh my God damn like am I gonna be
regular like you know what I'm saying
that's the real [__] ever am I gonna be
regular I thought of that as a kid all
the [__] but I look at myself other
people like you guys are content that's
cool but I can't I feel like I can climb
a building bro
yeah there's something even though it
was a broke I was broke as [__] as a kid
it was the worst bro but I knew like
it's still new I bet y'all be a
millionaire
I know yeah
that's crazy yeah I love that it's that
feeling you get man I don't know I can
remember little ask me I just remember
like I'm sure if you were up like that
like days will make fun of my clothes
gonna poor [__]
one day she was like um because I used
to see I think my car broke or something
and I was like man watch when I get my
cup back fixed she told me like man I
don't even say that type of [__] like
because God affected where you don't get
it I remember she told me she told that
[__] one time she probably don't even
remember that [__] stuck with me
remember where you were standing when it
happened
um
I remember my mom when I was a kid you
can't say fool you'll go to hell and I
was like I live in cholo town she just
didn't want me sound like all the cholos
as a kid so now I get when I'm old like
damn fool and I grew up talking like a
Surfers oh [__] yeah in New Orleans they
got a project called fishing the Fisher
project they call itself the fish of
fools everybody they had the whole
[__] citizen fishing fools
I got a lot of those homies
put 12 words but you just circulate
through 12. hey what's up fool hey don't
be a dick hey fool
sounds like those [__] kid things
that you just keep friends with animals
yeah it sounds like a soundboard
he used to always say are you serious
fool come on fool damn you sound like
you're born and raised from here that's
what you sound like right now
um sorry why are we getting off the
subject you got music coming up man um
who can you talk about if you have any
futures or anything
um or who you've been working with who
you would like to work with I've been
working with a lot of people I didn't
work with
um
Dirk album
um I got Dirk on my [__]
um
I've been working with a lot of people I
got trippy red on my own
um no cap on my album I don't even work
on this one I might see I I ain't really
been working on it forever
trying to make music yeah I'm saying
that's how I'm looking at it put it
together yeah just put that [__]
together that's what it is like Fuji's
gets in between that [__]
so what's like your routine in your
process right now as far as recording
oh you're just sitting there just going
with basically how you feel with the
music coming in yeah how I feel I wrote
one song in my whole life that was
probably one of my first songs like on
paper you're the only time you ever
wrote I wrote one time all right you
just go in there and just do it yeah I
did freestyle hmm see because that's
just how you be feeling at the moment
like
I'm be honest bro it doesn't sound like
you're just freestyling on any of this
[__] I know I'll be listening to it I'd
be like man ain't nobody gonna think I'm
freestyling but I swear I'll be
freestyle
damn I mean stuff like that you got more
like I don't want to say like a New York
presence but like I feel you really
rapping on there so yeah yeah it's the
energy I like the uh
was it vulture Island yeah I was like
the epitome of like yo it's a rap video
out here right now let's make a video
that's like Bay Area [__] to me when I
was younger the whole Block's outside
yeah I think that's how it was too
where'd you come up with the title of
all trying what's that mean I mean I
came up with the title I was making a
song
funny as hell and I'm like let's just
unfortunate because I was thinking of it
like while I was in the studio I was
thinking of it like me and my partners
like like this is an island you know
what I'm saying like this island outside
just can't come on that's how I was
thinking about it like when you come
over here just know it's sweet over here
besides to sit in the sun like vulture
Island that's him all right man at first
I was going into showing you eat
like like three four days before I
dropped the song I'm like change the
name of all time
I'll put this on everything that's crazy
I really did that
I forgot all about this
the stuff you work your ass off and
people like yeah that's tight and then
[__] you're like I'm just doing it right
now yeah it's the classic I got a song
called phone ringing that I dropped on a
vulture Island mixtape because I got a
mixtape called Welcome to vulture Island
I dropped a song called phone ringing on
it I added that song like three days
before I'm like
I just don't want it
then I the day I shot the video to it
I'm like um we're supposed to shoot
another video I'm like
no I like this one let's shoot this
video that's one of the biggest songs on
that team like see my performance [__]
worry about word but look it there it
goes when you meet fans and they're like
yo this is the lyric this is the first
time I ever heard you you do the same
thing like I remember I was listening to
what'd you say earlier and I heard Lil
Wayne I was in the Hills I was a bird
man like this is a GTA I'm in Grand
Theft Auto right now the DMX that's oh
it's DMX sorry you said DMX but see that
something stuck with you it's the same
thing like
right there it's like let's just throw
it out there then fans are coming up to
you it's if you could find that way to
bring it out of your audience what
someone brought out of you I think you
just like solidified them coming to
every show every time you come through
downloading your music you know what I
mean because they're a big fan of you
it's a big fan and then they get to see
you you really inspired me right now I
don't care because you're making me
realize what this is like this [__]
about just being you in 100 minutes you
know what I'm saying that's connecting
with the fans
get away from that like when you start
getting so big we said like like we said
earlier like
I feel like a lot of artists just you
know here's my [__] you like me uh-huh
I'm cool right I'm cool damn 22004. my
bad that was old school my bad Jesus
yeah but no once you connect other than
this doing interviews yeah doing
interviews great but do you do
personally do you do a lot of interviews
where people ask you like what are you
doing your little kid no it's usually
about like music [__] yeah so you get
the different side of people and that
different side makes you go
like
paid in full and [__] like I didn't
watch the movies the fact that you know
got all the Godfathers is shocking to me
I got to be honest because not just
because you're younger I mean I'm I know
we look young I'm [__] 10 years older
but
it's it's the value of like a [__] you
know you you're with somebody in your
grandpa's friend and he's like damn you
know Charles Bradley or you know you
know what I mean like if you want to
grow up a friend and he said and you
tell them you watched all three
Godfathers he's gonna be like
when I tell my my Grandma's friends oh
sorry for their son's my one of my
favorite shows like what the [__] you
know about Sanford his son like I got
the whole series [__] I love it
it's just it's just a different layer
and once you get layers people can go oh
there's more things
for Instagram it's something else
there's like substance there so see like
Peyton for all that [__] American
gangster's a great movie we even we just
get skated by that [__] I don't know why
we did but it doesn't get enough credit
yeah it just it just goes a show
soundtrack yeah and soundtrack uh
let me forget his name why you did that
I don't know man I just [__] it up
what is his name
I haven't watched it I heard it was dope
I seen one scene I'm like damn that's
just graphic it's like a longer version
of um a longer version of uh American
Gangster so if he didn't get busted you
know you know you know American Gangster
Denzel Washington was playing
was playing bumpy Johnson's driver that
he taught everything to
so that's what this is about this is
showing you Bumpy Johnson so it's
showing you well Denzel Washington got
everything from oh I didn't know any of
this I didn't realize that either yeah
this is a real I don't really think
about this real life yeah but you know
he's based on a true story about all
right so what's true so I just kind of
skated by him Johnson died in American
Gangster and left his throne to
didn't say I was to
so this is like the prequel to it
basically like what happened before that
this this is what happened before that
yeah I think it could be a this is
bumper Johnson story and how he taught
and how he taught him everything because
he was with him every day
and that's what it is tough I'm telling
you damn but I know we gotta wrap up but
yeah can we just say
he's not even an actor but Camron
crushed that role of Records
do you know Hustler is the rapper from
the bay ah nah that's who Rico reminds
me I'm about to tell you some real [__]
though
um come on Cameron was done Killer
Season like like Cameron been one of
them would act at night you never saw
Killer Season no that's some Smack DVD
[__] bro
I remember the season what's wrong with
you I never stopped this camera on best
film damn I'm missing out and I talked
about based on him somebody that's not
like yo I'm an actor IMBD you know what
I'm saying like yo you did a that full
crushed that [__] young ass age too oh
yeah so those are all good ass movies
and then you see you see Ace in the
Creed I'm like damn that's what's
getting oh yeah bro so this is Ace like
oh he kept his diamonds and bought a gym
huh
I don't know man I just wish there was a
part two but it would kill it I just
want to know what happened I just want
to know what'll happen man the real Ace
went on a Vlad TV you see that yeah I
told his story that [__] was crazy and
um the real Rico died
I got killed yeah
the king oh that's sad
he was a kingdom when he got out I'm
just saying that's this is what a you
never see you just got 20 years later
just got killed yeah it was like a year
ago right yeah
well that's a Saturday bro in the same
Hood too
he was insane that's how it goes [__]
that's all go it does that's how it goes
[__] that's sad damn we're all getting
all depressing you said that was a good
movie there was a good ass movies and uh
your album's coming out four God two
coming out at the end of April you have
a set date uh no not right now not yet
are you releasing any anything else I
might release a single or something but
other than that I really don't know I
might do it
good evening idea
hey the month of April is going to be
good for you man for sure and you always
remember like yo 420 on uh my 24th year
of life my album was coming out like
there's a little Milestones 21st
birthday what were you doing like I just
I'm happy to see what comes next man I'm
like we said when we were talking about
booking we're looking more like
oh this is sick I like what you're doing
this shit's tight and I like to see the
other side of people so this is sick too
appreciate you being here um where can
everybody find you because for some
reason if you don't type up on your name
after oh my God bro no for real nice
dude hey you gotta put it on the screen
rob49 up rob49 up on Instagram and
Twitter and Twitter I will give you my
Snapchat but no it'll be weird that's
just wild because it's a Russian
Roulette like is this a dick picture oh
like what the [__] your profile
it's not the Snapchat yeah I feel you I
feel you I get the same [__] I'm like
dude
dick or tits I hope it's just I hope
it's like the first one man no anyway uh
Snapchat don't do the Snapchat but
YouTube and we're gonna get your music
at like you're watching music or iPhone
9 that's all you gotta type in rob49 on
YouTube subscribe to my YouTube channel
I just hit it like like 120
000 subscribers [__] nice I'll give you
a little thing after for because we do
YouTube Heavy I gotta share a little tip
for when you drop stuff it'll
tickets live shows
down I appreciate you guys Marty
anything else thank you sir appreciate
you being here thank you
come back and let us know what you think
about the next time yes also take this
this is my brand inside it's full of
Edibles and pet and just take it if you
guys don't want to eat them give them to
a homie that wants to get high as hell
yeah I know somebody's gonna eat them
there you go yeah I hear something oh
yeah yeah oh my God just be very careful
with that yeah they're very they're just
super strong for real yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't advise you either right now if
you got other [__] to do wait to get on
the plane and watch belly and then eat
some sharks [__] bro I'm not eating this
[__] but I'm good I'm playing you're
gonna see you know when they do that
murder sexy room yeah don't put me on
that bridge actually roll with these
guys I appreciate you man thank you for
being here guys uh for Marty Rob 49 and
I this is the dope as usual podcast have
a dope ass day
thanks for watching the podcast if you
thought this was dope you'll like this
episode too and don't forget the best
way to support the show tell a homie